you know machine learning ai and deep
learning it's not a solve all
solution for everything it's it's really
about being able to identify patterns
in lots of data or complex data and
being able to come up with
with predictions as a result of that
[Music]
near how are you good how are you
michael
fantastic thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders you know it's
already night time obviously in israel
so even more thank you for taking the
time to join me
no worries uh standard working hours 100
working hours
for a ceo of a of an early stage startup
and that has to
obviously do both us and israel so
wonderful
you know near so much experience in the
machine learning and artificial
intelligence space
uh research and from and from google and
most recently the company
that you founded allegro and i'd love to
use these next
19 minutes or so so that i can learn a
little bit about where we're headed and
you know a lot of the people that are
viewing this some of them are technical
some of them are not so
i'm sure we let's try to find a balance
of how can we you know talk about this
industry
at a bit higher level and what
opportunities
are and what opportunities are and what
the constraints are
sure so tell me a little bit about
allegro really quick just so we can have
context of what you're interested in
and some of the things that you're
researching
absolutely so so um
actually we we you know we do a little
bit of research but uh
even you know research also on team
communication and building you know
building models
sure yeah sure sure i mean research
always has a specific connotation in ai
but but yeah basically where we come at
it or um
uh we're about engineering the research
and i'll explain
so um you know the thing about ai and
when i'm speaking about ai
you know in my context it's machine
learning and deep learning
um and uh basically it's a fundamentally
different paradigm on how to do software
right so traditional software is a very
logical linear development process
and it's at its essence it's basically
engineers um building um
algorithms to solve problems and then
coding them in a way that a machine
understands right so then the machine
can actually run it
whereas in in machine learning deep
learning what you're actually doing is
you're employing
algorithms to come up with the
algorithm to solve the problem right and
right this is and so you do this through
a process of iteration
uh and experimentation hence machine
learning
right so the algorithm supposedly learns
right
yeah um and so this is a very this is an
experimental process rather than
a standard software process and this has
fundamental implications on everything
else
right on the type of talent that you
need to to basically
drive development and maintenance of
this on on the type of tools that you
need
and how to integrate uh workflows to
make that work
and so uh what we do at allegro is we
basically provide
an end-to-end tool chain or platform
whatever you want to call it
um that basically supports the key
pillars or aspects of ai around the
paradigm so that our customers can focus
on
building uh and maintaining their
product or service
um so that they can focus and therefore
build a better solution
faster and more cost effectively right
so at the end of the day we're about
engineering the processes
uh that are specific to ai um
to make it uh uh you know more
productive okay so maybe give me you
know
a brief context and a rundown of what is
the life cycle of an ai
project in terms of let's say that i now
i want to take a team of three other
researchers and engineers i want to
solve my problem is that
that i want to know i want to know
what my dog is going to think next okay
so i have a new puppy
and i know that he has patterns i just
don't know what they are
of when he's gonna go bite the couch now
this and it's awful because i'm gonna
have to pay for this couch because this
is
you know a rental right so right so how
do
what is the life cycle of such a project
from a machine from a machine learning
researcher's perspective
so actually you hit actually the nail on
the head right i mean what that's one
thing to remember
for the non-technical audience right uh
you know machine learning ai
and deep learning it's not a solve all
solution for everything
it's it's really about being able to
identify patterns
in lots of data or complex data and
being able to come up with
with predictions as a result of that
right so you hit the nail on the head on
that
and so being able to understand when
your puppy is going to uh to bite the
couch
uh you you know you'll need to collect
data right so
to basically um uh you'll need to um
collect data about the puppy's behavior
right um for a period of time
during which uh he may you know bite the
couch or not and he's just acting around
right so basically in this case you're
probably gonna film him right i mean you
could
theoretically also put some sensors
around them and measure
other types of things uh related to to
to maybe his uh you know level of
anxiety or whatever and blood pressure i
should run right
now that the notebook and write logs of
every single thing he does
exactly right and then so basically you
know that's the first thing you need to
do i mean because
uh data what we like to say is it's
really the raw material that drive the
process
right um and so then what you're going
to do is you're going to have to uh
basically um you know
you're going to have to have a data
scientist or you're gonna have to find
someone uh that is going to figure out
okay what is the best
uh you know the best way to to address
this or to build a uh
a solution to to predict this and what i
mean by that is you want someone to be
able to
identify what's the right algorithms
there are a lot of algorithms out there
right
in deep learning they're called neural
networks and machine learning there's a
set of algorithms
right which is the one that's best
suited to solve this problem
and there are obviously different types
of algorithms each one for different uh
solutions optimized for them and then
you're gonna have to build basically an
experiment you're building basically an
experiment where you're saying i'm gonna
take this data i'm gonna assume this is
the right model for me
i'm gonna tune different parameters
around it you have some you know think
of it as a block where you can actually
tune and change some levers
and then you're going to run an
experiment and you're going to see the
results and
i want to also there is a
differentiation because i think there's
a misconception that
anybody who says i'm a machine learning
engineer or something like that
then people assume that you know they're
a mathematical genius that they're
sitting and they're
you know they're creating the they're
they're necessarily creating these new
un
unseen before algorithms but a lot of
engineers that are
working on machine learning today you
have all these democratized tools like
tensorflow and pytorch
and all these you know out of the box
tools where you can even if you don't
know machine learning at all
you can say yeah i have this data set i
i heard on a podcast that
this should be suitable to you know a
logistic regression
so let's just try it out then oh it
works or it doesn't work
it's true i mean so so a lot of the big
you know cloud providers uh
uh namely mostly you know you see google
amazon microsoft
and some others are providing tools that
enable
you know people who have you know basic
technical affinity to be able to to do
these things
uh but the important thing to remember
at least you know where i'm coming from
an industry is that these tools are
lowest common denominator but i'm able
to maybe solve a problem of a puppy but
once you get into situations where uh
you know the
the precision becomes much more
important because you know the cost
associated with a mistake
is going to be bigger say autonomous
vehicles right yeah
right then um you know it's not enough
to have a layman using these tools
you're gonna have to actually have
people who are much uh you know much
more knowledgeable
uh both on you know on different aspects
of this right so there's a lot of
aspects there are the people who
actually are going to
to use the neural networks and to do the
stuff and maybe even tweak them around
and even uh you know we we're working
with companies who even are
um um you know smart enough to actually
be able to
to build their own neural networks yeah
to then you know engineers who know how
to actually take that and build a
solution that's scalable solution
right and so there are many you know you
need to have a lot of professionals in
this process right so
it really sounds like it really sounds
like the 80 20 rule where you can get
you know 80
precision with 20 of the effort but if
you want to get 100 accuracy
and you want to make sure that your
autonomous vehicle is going to be
predictable
in these circumstances you're going to
have to put 100 of the effort and go
that extra mile
did you take a sneak peek at some of our
presentations because
yeah exactly and i've been hearing about
this uh from from birth basically
yeah it's uh it's it's exactly that uh
you know i heard somewhere and it's so
true i mean building a prototype
even building actually a prototype of a
autonomous vehicle
to to drive in in a you know in a
parking lot
is very very easy the problem is exactly
that to build a real product that's
exactly the 80 20 rule
wonderful okay so so you know allegro
how is it helping either you know
democratize
um machine learning and ai so that
others can use it or make it
more efficient and better for teams how
does this whole process work
sure so so we basically um
we help companies um in three or four
pillars
right so um the first one is what we
call experiment management
or process management and this is really
around how do you manage
this different process of experiments
right so you have a lot of
experimentation that you're doing
um and you need to basically be able to
pick and choose the best one compare
them go back and maybe take a different
direction in your
research etc so how do you actually
manage that process efficiently
you know that's one piece that we do uh
the second piece
uh and i'm going really fast high level
here right the second piece is
around um this new space called
ml ops right so it's the ai version of
devops right so in
devops in a nutshell it's about taking
a single discrete piece of code and
scaling up
you know over a lot of computers so that
it can work in scale right to service a
lot of
users or what have you whereas in ai
you're actually having lots of different
experiments running at the same time and
so you need to have
the problem is different you need to
have a way to scale up
lots of slightly different pieces of
code they're
about the same but they're slightly
different and it's a different problem
the other thing is
devops usually happens in production and
so in standard software
there's a very clear delineation between
development and production
whereas in ai the need for a lot of
compute power
begins really really early on yes you
know right after you built the initial
model you know you're gonna have to
take more compute power to to do bigger
bigger data sets
and so this is this is the area of
emelops and so
uh it's a very different problem than
devops and we provide
a really simple solution for that so
that um
companies uh who have data scientists
can self
self serve themselves because that's
oftentimes where the problem is
they're they're going to the devops who
don't know exactly what they need
and there's a lot of friction there so
that's the second thing that we help
with
um the third thing you actually own the
gpus and you may and you manage the
running or
are you how does that actually work over
there right we don't own the gpus
uh or or any of the underneath hardware
um our solution is 100 software
okay we basically provide an
orchestration and a queuing layer
to enable data scientists to do this it
can sit
directly on the hardware it can also sit
on scalable solutions like kubernetes
which were built for devops
but a lot of companies who have this
want to you know to have their ai also
on that so we basically have
this kind of like translation layer so
that the data scientists can build
solutions easily
and it then runs and it kind of you know
runs ultimately on kubernetes through
our system
yeah um so that's you know that's that's
the amalops part of it
the third pillar um is around
uh data management and what i mean by
data management is really metadata
management right because it's about the
insights of the data right when you're
looking at data think about your dog
right
the the video itself is meaningless
unless you basically say okay here's
where
you know your puppy bit the couch or
here where you know they started
starting
playing around or whatever that metadata
uh you know maybe it's nighttime or
daytime or it's winter right those are
the things that actually you know
potentially could affect
your puppy's behavior right and so those
are the things that you need to
manage um and the thing is that um you
need to understand
you know data skews and data biases
because ultimately
let's take an example from from uh in
autonomous vehicles
most of the time what you're dealing
with is these really rare edge cases
what happens when you're driving
and the sun is exactly uh you know
shining through the camera
and you're making a left turn and
someone's coming from the right and
there's a stop sign or whatever
those you know those edge cases are the
ones that you need to deal with
and they're rare and so you don't have a
lot of data on that
and so uh then what happens is actually
if you have too much data of something
else and not enough of these situations
your neural network your algorithm is
not going to
learn well so you have to rebalance the
data
etc so building a solution to do that to
really manage
metadata as raw material for your
process this is something completely new
companies like google microsoft amazon
have internal in-house solutions built
for that but 99 of the other companies
don't
right and so almost every startup
either claims or actually does you know
work ai work
yeah yeah we can we can talk about that
a different time but uh that's i mean
there's some amazing startups out there
but
uh you're right a lot of uh on on you
know
unsubstantiated claims are also out
there and so that's what
it doubles your evaluation within a
second so of course you do
and then i guess the fourth pillar is
about collaboration and
it's it's really it's about
collaboration and actually
uh efficiency of uh of your human
capital
so and this has multiple facets so the
first facet is
your data scientists really good ones
again we talked about the fact that you
know
we're solving problems for you know
companies who have very high standards
and not your layman's solutions and so
uh getting these
uh you know very highly qualified
research scientists and data scientists
uh super expensive and very hard to find
um
and so if you have them you want to make
sure that they're as productive as you
can
the second thing is researchers and data
scientists have a very different mindset
than engineers
yeah because again they're doing
research work and so but ultimately
you're building a product which is an
exercise in engineering
and so there's a friction there and the
idea is how do you actually make them
or how to actually get them to integrate
well into a larger product and
engineering team
so obviously these have a lot of aspects
around you know how to manage it
organizationally etc
but it also has an aspect of round
tooling right
for example how do you make sure that
you have a tool that enables a simple
handoff between something that the data
scientists build
an engineer can actually take and use as
a containerized solution that they don't
need to understand what's inside
right so we facilitate those things from
that aspect
so that um on one hand uh data
scientists can become much much more
productive but also at the same time
be able to hand off and integrate nicely
into the large organization
so those are the um um i guess four
pillars of
of how we help uh companies wonderful
and and where is it where is it
where is it at now so allegro where
what's happening in in realms of you
know in terms of the team and
and funding et cetera so we're uh
you know we're uh we're a series a
company we're about uh
30 people um you know we we're um
you know so we're um an open source
company so
most of our platform is is completely
open
um and so uh we're we're actually
undertaking what uh andreessen horowitz
uh uh
calls a uh b2b gross sales strategy so
we're you know we're pushing
on getting a lot of companies to to
adopt our solution
uh um you know knowing that they're
gonna upsell into
into at some point to some enterprise
solution and so that's going well where
you know i can't release numbers but
we're growing uh really really fast
that that's wonderful okay and here i
have each for just a few more minutes
but i i but i'd love to i would love to
pick your brain
what what are you most passionate about
in the realm of of the ai space
and if you like if you think you know
five years down the line
realistically what are the things that
you are most excited about
that i will get to experience in my 20s
now
what i'm most passionate about is is
what got me here in the first place i
mean and this is
you know i so i spent about a decade at
google and you know
after you are google and you're doing a
lot of uh uh
things that really you know impact huge
swath of humanity
really right it's it's you know you
really learn about
you want to innovate and you want to do
something that's impactful and that's
really that's been the driving force for
me
across my whole career how to actually
be in you know innovate and push
the envelope or be part of something
that pushes it to the next stage
and really be able to have a large
impact and you know i think that ai
obviously is going to have a large
a huge impact on humanity in so many
aspects and so for us it's really about
making that happen i think that there's
a really big
uh disparity between where the media is
today and what's actually happening most
of the companies are struggling with
this
and so to me if you're asking
realistically what we're going to see in
the next several years
is we're going to see a lot of the um
you know the things that you're already
seeing out of google et cetera
but become standard everyday things
where it's normal for you to do that
right if it's normal for you to talk to
a bot
right that's completely automated it's
it's you know it's normal for companies
to be able to automatically figure out
you know who are the best customers and
where they need to target it right it's
it's
it's very easy to be able to understand
what you're seeing in video cetera right
and
no you know i i had recently a talk with
with a product manager at waymo and one
of the
very interesting things that she
mentioned was you know the media and a
lot of companies were very quick
to to make these these crazy assumptions
that yeah by the year 2020 we're going
to have
vehicles on the road but and people
because people thought that
the problem was a little bit i think
easier than what it is and all of a
sudden
they got to 95 mark and then they
realized that that last sliver which is
critical when you're talking about lives
uh that's going to take a little bit
longer
so i agree and and i definitely look
forward to seeing where things progress
i'm very excited about my own studies
with ai and and getting a deeper
understanding myself to be able to
you know harness these qualities as well
and we you know
we're almost out of time but i have to
ask you my favorite question uh
i would love to know three words that
you would best describe yourself
very curious for that now yeah so you
warned me about this uh
right before but i didn't have time to
think about it but but let me let me
tell you about uh
so let me give a different answer
slightly different
when i you know when i look at the
leaders and managers that i
aspire to be like right i you know i saw
people who
are you know pushing the envelope who
are uh able to take bold decisions
i saw people who deeply care about
uh the success their success within the
context of the organization
not a me first and and also deeply care
about
um you know who you know their team and
the people that work for them
and their success again within that
context and then at the end of the day
uh you know having doing everything with
integrity
and so you know when you ask me this is
what i aspire to to be
i love it i love it and you know i think
it's just i'm sure it's such a
both fascinating difficult and fun
journey at the same time
to now lead a company that's growing
quickly and and you have to now really
formulate your own leadership style and
what does it mean
to be to be a leader in that in that
aspect and you're also i think
i recall you were a captain in the idf
as well which i'm sure
uh has a a lot of connections to some of
the things you're experiencing now
but but it sounds wonderful near best of
luck with allegro uh thank you for the
inspiration over these last 20 minutes
and i look forward to keeping in touch
thank you so much michael it's been a
pleasure
uh and and obviously all the success to
you and maybe you know you can come work
for us or use our tools done
all right take care take care michael
bye-bye